à
il ya 30 ans la nasa a lancé une capsule
témoin dans l'espace avec l'espoir de
contacter des formes de vie
extraterrestre selon moi une puissance
aliens envoyer des jeux vidéo
à l'assaut de la terre ça me paraît
logique
c'est une menace d'un genre inédit il
nous faut des experts en jeux vidéo sam
brenner champion du monde de pac-man sa
boum
l'oslo lemon sauf meilleur score de tous
les temps a senti plaide aussi connu
sous le nom de pire passoire et des
plantes le cador de donkey kong c'est
une plaisanterie howe est dissipée le
cycle que dépend le cycle
il ya des fantômes qui peuvent dégommer
pac man vous voulez des fantômes voalavo
fantôme allez ça roule
voilà
dites à personne que j'ai tué un jeu
trouble
tout sera prêt
dix secondes pour nous ça valait
on va assurer sinon c'est la fin du
monde
faut aller les affronter sur leur
terrain
donc qui quand
le seul jeu où tu es nul
je vous présente le créateur de pac-man
profession y voit ta vie ou est-ce que
vous allez vers voir c'est mon garçon
alors mon petit âge à moi qu'est ce que
tu vas grady sait trop rien
il est trop mignon tu es un bon garçon